avant de commencer ce que j'avais à dire
je voulais juste voir avec vous qui en
faites ce thème pas tellement bien avec
mon ami qui vient de passer avant au
moins on est parti des limites de sa
structure ao no limit
grâce aux sponsors et vraiment c'est
vraiment on est en plein dedans je vous
remercie pour ça imaginez vous
vous avez 22 ans vous êtes un jeune
étudiant
et vous avez votre meilleur ami votre
ami d'enfance qui a juste un an de moins
que vous qui a grandi avec vous que vous
connaissez depuis l'âge de 7-8 ans qui
vous appelle
parce que bon elle veut partager quelque
chose des ultimes avec vous une
information importante et vous annonce
que le séropositives au vih
c'est le genre d'information
à laquelle on n'est pas du tout préparé
lorsqu'on est touché directement en en
on partage
un café dans ce restaurant du plateau
que je vais jamais oublier juste au
niveau de nour al hayat là au dessus de
la station chez passé les stations
encore là mais cette image m'est restée
en tête
j'ai 22 ans
elle a 21 ans on a grandi ensemble
et pire que ça j'ai fait des études de
médecine les genres quatrième année de
médecine
je sais ce que le vih/sida veut dire à
l'époque et je reçois en face de moi
c'était informations
je suis complètement désarçonné c'est un
véritable choc personnel parce que en
tant qu'étudiant on voyait des malades
c'est vrai les malades étaient une
réalité mais ça restait des malades
c'était l'autre côté de la barrière là
vous avez en face de vous quelqu'un qui
vous le dis parce que vous êtes d'abord
son ami son ami d'enfance mais surtout
aussi peut-être parce que vous fait des
études de médecine et que vous avez
peut-être une réponse voire une solution
non
je n'ai pas de réponse pour elle
je suis complètement désarçonné les plus
jeunes n'ont pas connu ça mais un autre
époque
veillez sida était égal à mort c'est pas
que c'est à peu près ou pas non quand
vous avez le sida dans les années 80 90
ça voulait dire que vous allez mourir
alors est-ce que vous allez mourir dans
un an dans deux ans dans trois ans on
savait pas mais vous allez mourir
c'était terrible c'était la certitude
vous rappelez bien on n'avait pas de
médicaments
les médicaments étaient au nom comme on
dit et les malades et au sud
et cette différence là elle est restée
pendant longtemps alors on s'est dit que
ce qu'il faut faire
est-ce qu'on reste comme ça est ce que
on encaisse le coup
jeune étudiant intellectuelle on n'était
pas satisfait de la politique nationale
ont montré des malades dans des
situations où il était complètement
amaigri en train de mourir ça ne faisait
que s'aggraver cette discrimination et
on se dit non on va se relever et avec
un groupe d'amis en 93 on en train de
finir nos études de médecine avec deux
copains et en médecine et deux autres en
sciences éco on monte une ong qui
s'appelle ruban rouge côte d'ivoire et
on la crée avec mon ami et frère le
jeune rayess qui ont réduites par la
salle mais le hasard fait qu'il a voyagé
hier soir c'est vraiment dommage je
voulais lui rendre hommage
même s'il n'est pas là j'aimerais
vraiment pro novation de gênes pour
saluer
on s'est dit qu'on n'a pas de
médicaments on n'a pas de solution mais
qu'est ce qu'on a on a notre coeur qu'on
a notre amour on peut donner ce qu'on
peut à savoir la compassion le soutien
écouter l'autre donc ancré notre ong
c'est dans cette obsédante cette optique
là savoir apporter ce que la médecine
n'arrive pas à nous apporter et au moins
libéré la parole parce que à cette
époque là la discrimination la
stigmatisation était énorme
je dis pas que la disparue mais à
l'époque elle était incroyablement forte
et c'est là qu'on se retrouve face à des
limites de notre environnement
ses limites elles sont multiples elles
étaient avant tout familiale
je me rappelle d'un malade je suis en 7e
année on informe les malades de leur
statut et on leur dit qu'il faut
absolument qu'ils informent leur
entourage pour leur femme ou bien leur
mari et j'ai toujours le souvenir de
cette femme qu'on venait de soigner bon
mais pas trop hein mais mètres venait de
soigner mais moi en tant qu'étudiant
j'étais dans l'environnement et donc je
contribue à l'annonce de la maladie de
cette femme
on lui dit que quand c'est comme ça en
tant qu'épouse vous devez informer votre
mari pour que votre mari aussi vient de
se faire tester à l'hôpital et qu'on
puisse le traiter si lui aussi l'a
affecté on libère la dame
au bout de trois jours la femme revient
avec bagages et enfants devant notre
service parce que monsieur l'achat c'est
parce que c'est quand même le sida dans
la famille donc les familles les
familles n'ont pas su répondre
le mari ne pouvait pas dire à la femme
la femme ne peut pas le dire à son mari
l'enfant la maman ne peux pas le dire à
son enfant les familles ont été une
limite le milieu professionnel
on a encore des témoignages de personnes
qui du fait de la divulgation de mes
collègues qui n'avait pas le droit en
tant que médecin je n'ai pas le droit de
dire dans mon à société qui est infectée
ou pas malheureusement j'ai des
collègues qui ont dit à leurs patrons
telle ou telle personne était infecté et
subitement il ya des gens qui sont
licenciées parce qu'à l'époque quand
vous avez un collègue qui infecte et ça
veut dire que le sida va sauter sur vous
va bondir quand vous allez rentrer dans
la société donc on ne touche plus la
porte du collègue est affecté on ne
rentre pas dans son bureau au cas où on
sait jamais un virus qui plane dans
l'air et qui pourraient tomber sur moi
ce sont des témoignages de patients que
je vous dis c'est une réalité les gens
souffert de cette limite là mais c'est
aussi des limites de notre société
cette société qui refusait de voir le
malade
ces sociétés qui culpabilise et le
malade est encore plus nos religions
quelle a été la place d'une religion
face au vih le vih est avant tout le
péché c'était la maladie du sexe à celle
attraper toi qui as cherché qui est là
depuis je te parles tu cours à gauche à
droite voilà maintenant qu'il ya eu sida
c'est ce côté de moralisation permanente
a fait que les gens se sont enfermés
vers eux et c'est tout ça qui nous a
poussé à créer notre engagement cet
engagement qui voulait que que vous
soyez étudiant médecins travailleurs
chacun pouvait apporter bien soutient
une aide pour essayer de faire avancer
au moins ses limites là on avait trop de
barrières parce qu'on n'avait pas encore
les médicaments
l'ebit quatre médicaments viendront de
dix ans plus tard pour revenir à ma
propre vie moi j'ai fait médecine c'est
pas pour le sida à l'origine quand je
suis étudiant que je passe au match que
j'ai dit bon ça y est je vais faire
médecine c'est ce que je veux devenir
chirurgien bons rêves d'enfance et de la
chirurgie
depuis tout petit et puis toujours alors
j'arrive
a mené cette double vie professionnelle
ont des biens professionnels pour
s'entendent bien
mon épouse est là il faut pas qu'elle
est et confrère autre chose
je mène donc une double vie où je suis
engagé emotionnellement parce que c'est
vrai il ya mon ami qui est touché mais
après ça il ya loin dès qu'on a créé il
ya les malades quand on voit tous les
jours mais en même temps j'ai mon petit
d'aizier personnel de poursuivre ma
carrière chirurgicale et je le fais
alors non seulement je deviens
chirurgien mais augmente même ma
spécialité je deviens chirurgien
pédiatre donc je fais des formations en
plus de la chute générale d une
quinzaine d'années je revenais de stage
je veux un stage en rangée ou c'était
pour clôturer match chirurgie
pédiatrique donc je revenais exercé en
tant que chirurgien pédiatre mais entre
temps notre ong avaient vraiment grandi
on avait pu acquérir depuis les années
2000 un centre à yopougon qu'on appelle
le centre plus c'est quelqu'un qui nous
habille nouvellement offert une maison
et c'était avant tout un lieu d'écouté
passé comme on n'avait pas de
médicaments mais au moins on recevait
les malades ont leur donner les conseils
médicaux on faisait ce qu'on pouvait à
l'époque pour ceux qui ont connu ça en
donner le cotrimoxazole safadi bactrim
c'est un antibiotique pour éviter
certaines infections les plus courantes
mais surtout on permet aux gens de venir
parler et donc au moment où je pars en
stage en france on était en train de
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle les
groupes de parole des groupes de parole
c'est d'un ensemble d'une trentaine de
malades qui se réunissent une ou deux
fois par semaine pour échanger sur alors
ça c'est pour se libérer l'esprit
moi je suis malade je peux même pas dire
à mon frère je veux pas le dire à ma
femme je veux pas le dire à mon mari je
peux pas me le dire à ma soeur mais au
moins j'ai un endroit où il ya d'autres
patients que moi il ya des collègues des
amis avec qui je peux échanger
on est en train de mettre en place
ses goûts de parole quand je suis parti
en stage pour ma chirurgie n'oubliez pas
que j'aie chirurgien sauf que m après
quand je reviens un samedi après midi je
me rappelle je voyais au couvent au
centre plus et j'arrive comme par hasard
c'était pas prévu j'arrive comme par
hasard à ces groupes de paroles qui sont
en fait des moments où les personnes
s'expriment et c'est là que je découvre
combien ce que nous avons fait était
grand et cet engagement l'a fait que je
prend un virage professionnel et je
m'engage complètement dans contre le
sida
cette lutte la ramener à découvrir ce
que je ne connaissais pas je découvre
l'autre je découvre un autre monde
je travaille dans le milieu carcéral je
découvre la difficulté d'être médecin
est encore plus de soigner dans le
milieu carcéral
je découvre la réalité de ce qu'on
appelle les hommes qui ont des rapports
sexuels avec des hommes classiquement
qu'on appelle homosexuels dans nos
sociétés qui sont marginalisés qui sont
décriés je découvre surtout le travail
que je fais actuellement
projet de recherche sur les
travailleuses du sexe et fille qu'on
voit dans la rue leur réalité
je découvre aussi le monde de la drogue
avec ces personnes qui sont des urls
drogue et qui sont en fait de manière
simple ceux qui sont différents de nous
on a toujours l'impression que l'autre
est différent que c'est pas nous quelle
est en tout cas de notre regard est ce
qu'on se pose la question quel est ton
regard pour mon frère ma soeur qu'elle
est on regarde vis-à-vis de la fille qui
vend son corps au carrefour
quel est ton regard vie la vie de cet
homme qu'on appelle le quel est ton
regard vers celui qui utilise la drogue
et ses regards là c'est ce regard là
justement de compassion que je voudrais
vous partager pour vous dire combien
lorsque vous vous engagez vous devez
changer de regard
vous devez lever vos barrières il faut
que ces barrières l'appui sauter et
c'est cette barrière là qui fait que
justement on arrive à lutter contre les
phénomènes de discrimination de
stigmatisation tels que finalement on va
à la rencontre réellement de l'autre je
ne regarde plus l'autre parce qu'il est
différent de moi parce que j'ai les
barrières sociales j'aimais bairi à
familiale des mais marié traditionnels
je regarde l'autre comme étant un être
humain une personne qui est simplement
comme moi mon frère le cousin et
peut-être homosexuel je ne sais pas mais
si dans ma tête je suis fermé à quel
moment je vais apporter mon soutien à
quel moment je vais essayer de ne pas le
juger parce qu'il est comme ça
à quel moment enlève nos barrières de
discrimination nos barrières de
stigmatisation qui sont en fait le vrai
challenge
aujourd'hui trente ans plus tard le sida
n'est plus égale à mort comme on l'a
fait au début mais illégale à vie parce
que on a des traitements sont là des
médicaments mais on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que les gens ne veulent pas
savoir leur statut on ne tombe dans un
deuxième challenge
je n'ose pas demander toute l'année qui
ont fait des tests mais moi j'ai pas
demandé qui avait fait sauter du vih ici
parce que c'est une affaire personnelle
mais
en 2018 il est interdit de ne pas
connaître son statut en 2018
il est interdit de se fermer les yeux
parce que la solution elle est là la
solution que les réels et le changement
de venir nous devons donc être force de
lever des barrières lutte contre la
discrimination de lutte contre la
stigmatisation pour aller à la rencontre
réellement de cette autre et tout ça
pète
le malade monsieur surtout cet autre
différent moi ce que la lutte contre le
sida m'a apporté ça n'a rien de médical
c'est le rapport humain que j'ai pu
avoir avec des personnes que je pouvais
sentir sang ou de croire différentes
je suis dans un programme où je mets en
place des projets de prévention
vis-à-vis des travail du sexe et on
était donc à bouaké avec mon collègue je
me rappelle de ceux de cette anecdote on
était assez dans un maquis et donc je
devais me présenter aux filles
le projet alors la preuve c'est un grand
mot un jeu pas rentrer dans des thèmes
techniques mais sachez qu'aujourd'hui il
existe des médicaments qu'on peut
prendre pour éviter de s'infecter
lorsqu'on est de les infecter
ce n'est pas pour tout le monde c'est
pour ceux qu'on appelle les populations
à risque ce qu'on appelle les
populations vulnérables
sans rentrer dans beaucoup de détails
donc je devais expliquer donc je me
rappelle on est autour de quelques
verres de goudron des bières un désolé
pour le non mais c'est çà et là on est
d'où on est deux médecins et on a quatre
ou cinq filles qu'on devait pas ce que
c'était les leaders de leur groupe parce
que dans cet environnement il ya des
leaders et une organisation et donc on
devait commander à manger on a commencé
à commander les poulets qu'à un moment
donné il ya le téléphone d'une des
filles qui sont tentants cabon et alan
le dos qui m'a appelé major revenir ne
finissait pas le boulet donc attendez
moi donc ça a été le cas elle a dû
partir au bout de quarante-cinq ne
l'était le revenu après son rendez vous
comme vous comprenez et
et ça nous a montré que passer des
soirées de relaxation de purement
amicale mais surtout des changes
ça m est soi même c'est pas élevé la
d'autres personnes ca s'élève soi même
parce qu'on arrive à avoir un
comportement humain vis-à-vis de l'autre
libérons-nous crois et je voudrais
simplement conclure par cette citation
de mère teresa que j'aime beaucoup
nous réalisons que ce que nous
accomplissons n'est qu'une goutte dans
l'océan
mais si ça n'existait pas dans l'océan
elle manquerait soyons cette goutte
d'eau qui remplira l'océan afin de
dépasser nos limites
[Applaudissements]